what does it mean to see the event back
and bigger than ever this year it is
nice I mean Vanderpump obviously throws
an incredible event uh but you know to
have an event with such a purpose like
that is is incredible and we definitely
Bond over pet adoption and every animal
um so it's it's nice to be on the board
of Vanderpump dogs and uh and be able to
help out as much as I can
ever run Vander pumps the world right
now little thing called scandival 24
hours out for the finale but I overheard
you have not watched it yet how hard is
it to not have watched it no idea the
amount of texts we're like well one
Lisa's like come over and watch it with
me I'm like I can't because he was in
Miami and I said I swore that I wouldn't
watch it
um so I have been not on social media
today or anything because I don't want
to see any Clips I want to watch this
and it's glory but I mean it's it's the
it's the cast that keeps on giving it's
like the new Monica Lewinsky and Bill
Clinton I mean it shocked the world
apparently
a lot of them are here tonight not not
the direct players but some players do
you have a number one question you're
going to try and get answered inside oh
my gosh no I think we know pretty much
all the answers to this point uh you
know we've we've run into business
basically the whole cast in the last
couple months so that's all that's all
we can talk about when we see them like
okay yeah what do you know about this
yeah well you also are in the headlines
a lot because of this podcast every week
they've new headlines pull out of here
have you paid attention to any has any
surprised you no not at all I had no
idea they were writing about ourselves
oh yeah there's new things every week oh
yeah
great because I'm like because I get in
trouble because I speak too much
um so yeah I'm always kind of putting my
foot in my mouth but the latest one was
you saying you basically were not making
money when you were in NSync
[Music]
for you oh yeah well I mean I made a
whole documentary on it so I don't think
that was a surprise to too many but yeah
no we did not make uh the money people
fake yeah I mean you still did okay I
mean we made some money at the end but
it's not near what we rode yeah well the
rumor mill has it that maybe more money
is coming your way because back sync is
getting talked about again and again is
there is it is anything happening any
movement uh nothing with backseat
usually it's this time of year we do get
back together because it's usually for
the pride season we like to do charity
but the boys are super busy over in
Europe right now so I don't think we're
going to be able to get any of the
members to do the back seat this year
but when they're back we'll definitely
try to find something because we love we
love working with those guys okay 2024.
before then the twins will enter
hopefully not but maybe they're terrible
twos right they're entering it now
apparently my mom says they're already
started uh so yeah especially our son
our son's getting a little he's a terror
he's a terror
so other than the the terrorizing you
what is the best part of being dads at
this stage of their lives them hugging
you yeah right now they they hug and
they yell da da Papa and like when you
walk into the room they just light up
and it's oh it's it's amazing and our
favorite little trick now is all we have
to do is Kevin and they go
home alone
ah
I just somehow just learned to do that
yeah it sounds like they might be
entering the business then I hope to God
not
[Music]